it's kind of weird it's come so famous
the upside-down spider-man yeah yeah cuz
presumably you don't know you don't know
but I remember Sam Raimi giving me a
book of kisses it was a little like
coffee table book you can buy like a
little cute book of movie kisses he was
like let's try and make this one as epic
as these kisses these other famous
kisses so I thought that was oh that's a
nice idea Yeah right
you know you won't see but it yeah I
never expected it to be one of those
things you know you never know when
you're making some damn but it really
has become iconic yeah so we wondered
how hard it was to do because obviously
it's not straight full oh no
dawn dawn while even chatting really
mostly what you've been doing is not
kissing Bear Grylls
yes that's David nothing wishing I could
I need me to direct you guys yeah so
about Barrett you're okay to hang upside
down right to hang out sit down but it
was raining so we got to pour this over
your head like part of the reason it was
difficult because water was going into
his news
what would fun for you we're really
gonna recreate we don't even have a suit
okay there's a trapeze are you sure yeah
uh yeah I mean I give it a go
okay so okay so that looks really high
can you do that
yeah when get out there okay good luck
always take jacket off jackal okay he is
serious okay he tucked his shirt look at
him go
oh he's like a moon himself he's like a
moon cake
Oh
hey spit it out is that
so sorry I left that in from early I
always let travel with food on the go
I'm ready for my smack I come and then
doing it just me just King here we go
here we go oh there's one more in there
isn't family doesn't feel so much fun oh
why do man oh you're so hot
I'm sure
yeah that's what eyes what was really
dangerous about that you know all the
dangerous things bears done yes you just
give them bear so many diseases we live
dangerously on this day
I feels like that very elegance in some
way what happens is the car gets out out
of control and I actually do crash into
the car and make it there like Jamie get
out of the way Tom are you okay